now hanging on to batman spend may have
eased the pressure on the labour leader
kyoda for now but even his deputy says
that people don't quite know what he
stands for
and an exclusive poll for sky news found
this week that
seven out of ten labour members would
prefer to see the mayor of greater
manchester andy burnham
as leader how long before another
leadership
challenge let's ask sakir's most scenic
shadow cabinet colleague rachel reeves
rachel reeves um battling span a narrow
squeak but you won
peter mandelson says this gives uh sakir
until
september to come up with a case for
remaining
leader of the party um do you agree
well it was a great result in batley and
spain i can't tell you
how pleased i am that kim ledbeter is
going to be joining me
in parliament on monday tomorrow as the
member of parliament for batley and
spain and
it's a seat that means so much to all of
us in the labour party and
kim is an inspiration she will shake up
westminster
in every good possible way and that
by-election which
i fought hard in as well it's very near
to me in
leeds west was a by-election like
none other that i have seen during my 25
years
involved in the labour party and in
politics it was a
a campaign full of so much hatred and
division stoked by people from outside
of batley and spain
and that victory on the in the early
hours of friday morning was a victory
for decency over division
for hope over hatred and for integrity
in politics and
that is the labour party that kia
stammer stands for
and it is the labour party that is
embodied
by the campaign that kim and the team
ran
in badly and spent so i am delighted by
the result and can't
wait to see kim get started as mp
in westminster and in her community i
fully understand that
but do you agree with the mandelson
deadline of september
look kia is elected as leader of the
labour party today i'm setting out
ambitious plans for labour for how as
chancellor i would ensure that we buy
make and sell more
in britain and i think that the party in
batley and spend came together
under kia's leadership with kim as the
candidate it showed
everything that is best about the labour
party uh and
under kia's leadership and with kim in
parliament i think that we can
build on that success in batley and
spend going into the summer
then with our party conference and then
uh campaigning at the next general
election lightweight campaigns in batley
and spend
go on for more victories going forward
okay well you're not disagreeing with
with lord mendelson but you are
stressing the excellence of york
you're you're stressing the excellence
of your candidate
um under kier's leadership
we won in badly and spent okay will take
us into the next election
and i believe that that results in the
early hours of friday morning
is the start of more victories for labor
all right before we leave batman spend
you spoke of
the hatred and division being sowed
in that election campaign as did um
zakir
on friday morning who exactly was sowing
hatred and division
well i mean i was there on many
occasions
and i saw some of the behaviors of
george galloway
and his campaign uh and the
violence and aggression shown towards
both kim and other labour actors
there is no place for the sort of
behaviour that we saw in batley and
spain
in any election but especially in a
place
like battle and spring that has been
through so much in the last five years
or so and deserved
so much better than what they saw during
this by-election campaign and the people
of batman spain rejected that
and they voted for kim and kim is now
their mp and i know that kim would do
everything in
her power to bring the community
together as she has
over the last five years running schemes
like mooring common battery and spen
and i am so proud of kim but also
of the people of batley and spain thank
you for being so clear in pointing the
finger
at mr galloway does that
mean that either the 8 200 and
odd people who voted for him didn't
realize what he was about
or that they actually like the idea of
hatred and division
what's going on there there was a huge
amount of fake news being pushed out
in that constituency and there was the
whipping up
of tensions that has no place in our
democracy
kim now has a job to do to bring that
community together
i know that she can do that and will
start on that work
immediately i don't um
hold it against anyone for voting for
different parties
but the role of an mp is to bring
communities together whoever they voted
for
and show that decency and hope and
integrity can triumph
as it did in battley and spain last week
there is something that that comes out
of this um
whole well two things that come out of
this uh campaign first of all um
labour party issued a leaflet showing
boris johnson and narendra modi the
prime minister of india together
with a caption saying don't risk a tory
mp who is not on your side what was that
about why mr modi
well if you look at some of the actions
by boris johnson
uh during the course of this pandemic
but one of the things that
stands out very sharply is the failure
to close the borders properly to protect
us from new
variants of the virus including the
delta variant
and the prime minister uh prime minister
johnson wanted
his trade uh visit to uh india to to get
a trade deal but he put at risk
the vaccine roll out and allowed new
variants to enter
the country that is not responsible that
is not acting
in the national interest and labor
called on the government to close down
that border to protect the uk long
before the prime minister
eventually woke up to the reality the
rising number of cases
and the risk to our successful
vaccination program it is unusual to
have a foreign leader
on the leaflets of a candidate uh
in a local by election i just want you
to
clear up the labour view on the
allegation that this was i think the
words are being used our dog whistle
uh to muslim voters that um
actually the tories are in some way
anti-muslim
and that they identify with um what is
said to be an anti-muslim government
led by mr modi there's none of that
going on here
i don't um accept that um that
that that insinuation um trevor and what
we saw
in batley and spain was underhand
tactics
by galloway and his campaign bringing
people from outside to whip up that
hatred and
division with actual violence and
aggression towards the labour candidate
harassing intimidating chasing her down
the street and also to labour
activists that is the true nature of
what was happening
in batley and spain but the people of
that community rose above that
and returned kim as their mp last week
that is a great result
for labour it's also a great result for
batley and sten
all right let's talk about what you want
to talk about today which is the pro
your promise that the labor government
would make buy and sell
more in britain and that you'd bring
more jobs home
is this some an update to gordon brown's
pledge
of british jobs for british workers
it's very different from that this is
about a post-pandemic recovery plan
and how as chancellor i would ensure
that we support
high street small businesses and jobs
and industry
across the united kingdom as we address
some of the big challenges that we
face as a country and i put together a
three-point plan
to buy make and sell more in britain
and that includes using all the tools at
government's disposal
to do so so for example with procurement
to use stretching targets in procurement
to
award more contracts to companies
creating jobs and skills and
apprenticeships here in britain
to help businesses who want
post-pandemic and also post-brexit
to reassure jobs to make their supply
chains
more secure and resilient to help them
to do that
and also to sort out the big gaping
holes
in the brexit deal that the government
signed last year
to make it easier for british industries
and workers to export goods and services
across the european union
especially in our creative industries
professional services
and in farming and fisheries as well and
with that three-point plan
we can ensure that we're buying making
and selling more in this country
ensuring that the uk economy is firing
on
all cylinders and that we are more
secure and more resilient
in face of the sorts of shocks that any
economy
and especially one that's been through
everything we've been through
in the last year and a half to ensure
that we are more secure and resilient
in the face of those shocks i i think
this is what um distinguished economies
economists like yourself call a
non-tariff barrier so let's take an
example
and see how this would work in reality
biggest construction project in the
country pretty much uh hs2 high-speed
line um six months ago the bosses of hs2
picked a small group of construction
companies uh
to compete for contracts worth two and a
half
billion pounds for new rail lines now
just
one of the companies they picked is
british
would your proposals mean that hs2
when they make their decision would be
more likely
to pick the british company
i think that's a really good example
trevor because whether or not you think
that hs2
should go ahead and i know there are big
differences of opinion on that
i think we can all agree that that
investment should benefit
jobs skills apprenticeships and
businesses here
in britain because it is in our national
interest to create those high-skill
well-paid jobs and what my proposals
that i'm
i'm setting out today of how i would
approach this as chancellor of the
exchequer
would say that when you look at the
different bids that come in for any
project whether it be hs2 or offshore
wind or whatever it
is you can look at the plans of the
businesses bidding for that contract
to see what impact it would have on the
wider uk economy what strategic
value a bid has and if it is creating
jobs
in this country high skilled well-paid
jobs and apprenticeships
and that means that we're building up
that skill set so we can export around
the world
those bids should get more weight than
bids that are creating no jobs no skills
and no investment
in this country so it's not saying that
we won't give
um contracts to to foreign companies
absolutely not but it is saying
like in france and like in the united
states we would take into account
the social impact of any public
procurement
other countries do that because they
know it is strategically important
and yet in the uk we don't use those
powers that we have at our disposal and
that is a mistake and i would do that
differently
so you you say this is a good example um
so as chancellor what you would do is
create an environment in which
the in that case the british company
balfour beatty would
be favored so you would be leaning on
hs2 bosses
toward the contract to a company
implicated in the 2005 hatfield rail
crash
a company whose management has been
black was blacklisted
because uh it uh because it blacklisted
trade union
activists and still faces legal actions
from some unions
and the company which in 2019 was
suspended
for from bidding for government work
because it consistently made payments to
small and medium-sized
businesses late is that sort of company
that labor wants to see getting the work
because it's got a union jack on its
website
trevor it wouldn't be me as chancellor
leaning on
public bodies to award contracts what it
is about is
changing the procurement framework so
you can take into account
labor standards job creation in this
country and
environmental standards as well so there
is a level playing field
for businesses doing business in this
country and we take into account the
whole value
of the bids including the impact it
would have
on the environment on labour standards
and on jobs in this country
as i say under w2lto rules
under the trade agreement that we did
with our european partners last year
these things are possible
other countries do it because i know it
is strategically important
we should as well and that would ensure
that we create
more good jobs for small businesses and
large businesses
here in britain and that is the right
thing to do
it's not what is happening at the moment
in a whole range of government contracts
whether it is
offshore wind or hs2 or trident
submarines
we need to do things differently because
we have to grow the industries of the
future and ensure that there are more
good quality high-pay jobs in every
corner
of our country and as chancellor of the
exchequer
i would use every tool at my disposal to
ensure that the uk economy is firing on
all cylinders
and creating more good quality jobs that
you can raise the family on
just yeah so one very quick last
question this is your first
big announcement says shadow chancellor
your predecessor
uh john mcdonnell said that you can't
understand capitalism
without reading karl marx's dash capital
have you had that privilege
i haven't trevor had that privilege of
um reading
uh it but i studied economics for my
degree and for my master's degree i've
worked for many years
at the bank of england at the british
embassy in washington as an economist
and for halifax bank of scotland so
i hope my credentials speak for
themselves and as chancellor
i would do things differently but always
ensuring
that our policies are costed that they
add up and that they are in the best
interests
of the british people okay i'm sure mr
mcdonald's got a spare copy to lend you
if you
want it rachel reeves thank you very
much